hi there here's some things to do of
your new college student get your room
ready check make some new friends yeah
find yourself suddenly perimenopausal
check silly oh yeah okay hello all this
mediation is here to help facilitate
your divorce you will all be civilized
and you will please address all speech
to me to you so even if we want to talk
to you all know that we can I mean if I
wanted to say Dina I am going to have a
beautiful life with your husband Dean I
can't believe you brought her Christine
I can't believe you shacked up with a
[ __ ] I just say for the record I just
needed an upgrade in my life Deana
son of me please I'm sorry you son of a
[ __ ] you're the son of a [ __ ] you're
the son of a [ __ ] yes 23 years of
marriage just down the Jews something
terrible woman that doesn't even have
her to greet I know what I'm gonna do
let me see you staying at home and being
your mom but I regret not getting my
degree
that's why mom just enrolled in college
beep beep beep it's me I want the full
experience oh hell no I don't know
what's better it's the mom perm or the
mom's boobs
these allow this one to suckle at these
teeth for 28 months I've lured them
around my office proudly isn't the time
get ready for the world
oh I can
unbelievable chocolate it is we bark so
maybe I would probably hold off from
having any more just cuz I what is it
[Music]
for 20 years I worried about what I
wasn't doing right when I could have
been doing better you have a moment here
if you take it mom
don't jump to conclusion in here looks
like my mother is doing the walk of
shame out of a frat house okay
yes technically that's what's happened
watch them you know what I'm older and
wiser this essentially a Google ask me
anything
turn off your google it can't be turn
okay I don't like it I did not know they
were gonna be here what is on your lobes
Dan it's an earring what works for
Harrison Ford
Harrison Ford blew up the Death Star and
free to galaxies what have you done damn
you